Hey youtubers, it's Charlie. This is gonna
be my Agent Carter episode 7 video
we only have one episode left and then
the next week after that
Agents of SHIELD is coming back so I'll try to explain what the schedule is.
There hasn't been any confirmation about
season 2, but if they say something
before the finale airs I'll be sure to
include in that video next week.
So, just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet, starting
with top five moments.
Number 5: Doctor Faustus's flashback.
The character's name
is Doctor Ivchenko but he was holding
that Doctor Faustus book so everyone
thinks he might be Doctor Faustus from
the Marvel Comics.
The show runners are kinda sidestepping
that, like they're avoiding
directly calling him Doctor Faustus
but you can think of him that way.
He has the same type of powers that Doctor Faustus has.
In the comics he's a HYDRA character
connected to the Red Skull, but because
the antagonists are Russian, because Leviathan's Russian on the TV show,
I think they're just
trying to separate this character
from the Marvel Comics.
It seems like based on this flashback
he's a good person, he's a psychiatrist
trying to help soldiers with PTSD or
shell shock,
the look on his face right here
does not look like he's trying to do
something nice. This is like the look a
villain has on their face.
Hopefully they'll explain how he got
tied up with Leviathan,
because when we had the Black Widow flashback, when he had Dottie's flashback,
he was just sitting in that chair.
Moving on to number 4: Agent Carter gets interrogated.
This is like the fish shake WTF from the
episode just because
we as the audience know she is totally
innocent and the SSR
is way behind to the story so we have to
wait for them to catch up with the narrative.
And nothing is more frustrating that
watching a protagonist waste time
treating one of their teammates like an
asshole. Peggy he even said it:
'you are wasting precious time'.
The team comes around, they start believing her
but, you know, if you have made a
connection with the Agent Sousa character
and Agent Thompson and these other characters,
you feel this crushing remorse of being a
douchebag to Peggy.
It's kinda hard to get excited about an
episode or a story or a scene
when you feel awful about yourself.
I feel like that's one of the fundamental issues the show:
is that, at times it can make you feel
like an asshole. Imagine what would
happen if the Avengers were just jerks to
each other all the time.
It would be such an unlikeable franchise.
That's - that's why they have to have that moment where they come together in the episode,
like you have to have that win, that
team-based win and I feel like because
Agent Carter's
only eight episodes, it takes longer to
get there, they have less time to spend
on that.
So can still walk away after this
episode feeling kinda terrible about yourself.
You guys can let me know if you agree but do you feel like these characters
fighting with Peggy makes you feel worse about yourself?
I feel like it's really hard to get excited about scenes like this,
which is why was like a big WTF for me.
Moving on to number 3: Peggy tells the
truth.
Jarvis' confession was a nice twist.
He's like the pressure release valve in
the episode. He's serves this really
important function as Peggy sidekick.
It's like he needs to embody the spirit of
adventure, but be weak enough to make
Peggy seem like the real hero.
Like when they're together you never
confused about who the sidekick is.
He's like the Samwell Tarly
to Peggy' s Jon Snow.
And I just love how the show plays around Howard Stark's absence.
The real reason I think Dominic Cooper
isn't around every week is mostly
because an availability issues and cost.
And I kinda think the people are
more familiar with his character, so
you start to unconsciously think about it as
the Howard Stark show
and Peggy would turn into a supporting
character regardless of the show being
called Agent Carter.
Sometimes that can happen when you have characters that are so popular they just
overpower the narrative.
It'd be like putting on of the Avengers on
the Daredevil show every week.
What're you gonna get more excited about:
Daredevil parkour or Iron Man's new armor?
That being said it's a really good
problem to have when you have characters
that are too popular to be in a story.
I mean it's like an embarrassment of riches. Speaking you which now that the SSR
knows all about Captain America's blood
don't you just wonder what's gonna happen to it? I mean right now it seems safe
but we're in the early stages of HYDRA's infiltration.
It just seems funny that they have all that
Stark tech just lying around their lab, like it's no big deal.
Moving on to number 2: Agent Dooley takes one for the team.
Thanks to that whole hypnosis sequence
we finally get to see his family.
It's always weird when you hear about
characters all the time but you never
see them on screen
Most of the time that's actually used as a
comedy device.
Like 'oh, I can't believe my wife. She won't get off my case.' and you just never see the wife.
When they were walking through the lab and he picked that vest up for the first time
I was actually expecting the camera to
reveal it as some sort of prototype Iron Man armor
I guess you could think of it that way.
You can think of it as like arc reactor prototype.
They never fully explain without power
sources, but it does sound like the arc reactor
as Tony Stark described it in the first
Iron Man film.
He just says that it was an energy source that his father could never get to work properly,
and Jarvis when on and on about how
unstable all their tests were.
Agent Dooley sacrifice did go a long
way towards humanizing his character,
making a little bit more likable. He's
been kinda hard sell but I guess you
could understand where his logic is
flowing from.
I mean he's the boss, he has to go with
the fact that are presented to him.
It didn't seem like the way he treated
Peggy had anything to do with her being a woman,
at least after the first couple episodes.
I wasn't super connected to the
character so the death probably wasn't
quite as meaningful for me as
say like when the other characters like
Agent Sousa if he had died.
But I do like the way the eulogized him with that dream sequence.
I mean that - that was really nice, there
was a fitting way to go out.
At heart he's just a family man.
And my number 1 moment: Dottie and Doctor Ivchenko test Stark's nerve gas.
So they never given a real name
just Item 17, but it works just
like the weapon
in the King's Men movie. I know that's kinda meta because you can think of
Nick Fury as being the villain in the
movie because it's Sam Jackson.
I won't spoil it if you haven't seen it
but there is a scene that's very similar to this, in the movie.
The place where the film the episode the Agent Carter episode,
was actually the Los Angeles Theater that
was built in 1931.
They took a whole bunch of pictures from
the inside, it's really cool.
It kinda reminds me of an episode earlier this season on Gotham
that they shot inside of a theater, but that
shoots in New York and Agent Carter shoots in Los Angeles,
so it's two different places. There's
this really funny thing going on like if you
ever saw Inglorious Bastards
it's like that Nation's Pride screening
where the theater burns down.
The idea movies inside movies. They
presented in a fairly straightforward way
I don't think that that reel that they were watching was intended to be anything crazy or specific.
So let me know what was
your favorite moment from the episode,
and here's my big question for you:
they said Leviathan is coming, the
last episode is called Valediction
which basically means farewell. So, do you think
that this is going to be some sort a big
general attack or do you think that a
big villain is gonna step forward?
I know they presented this Doctor Faustus character as the main villain but
it seem like he got drowned in the
service with Leviathan too, so
I'm wondering if there's someone above
him, and if they're doing their job in the
narrative is really tightly
constructed that we probably met that villain already.
Think of it in the terms of the Flash. The Flash is like a good benchmark for really well
constructed narratives.
You meet all the main characters, all the
ones that are really important in the
first episode
so you open and you close the narrative
with the same group of people,
I already mentioned most of the Easter Eggs that I saw but if you guys saw
any others just reading below in the
comments. I'd say my only thumbs down in the
episode has been the villain character
development.
I mean, we know Leviathan is the villain but we really don't know more than they're just some sorta
vague Russian organization. We don't know if it's a person and we have no idea
what their real motives are.
I mean, yes, they want Stark Tech and yes, they probably want to take over the world
but that feels like it's too vague to be
interesting. World domination is
such an old plot device that it's hard
to take seriously.
So fingers crossed that the twist in the
finale makes the conflict feel a lot
more personal to Peggy, Jarvis, Howard
Stark.
It's just like on the list of possible twist
that you can give an audience
the villain turning out to be a friend
of yours is usually a little more rewarding
than like a Hail Mary (?)
situation where a villain you've never
seen before steps in and says 'it was all
me I did it all'.
Like I said, no confirmation on
season two. Hopefully they'll make an
announcement before the finale next week.
That's called Valediction, that's the title of
the finale. Be sure to subscribe to get
my video for that.
The next week after that SHIELD comes
back so we'll be back to weekly SHIELD videos pretty soon,
lots of Inhumans and Secret Warriors comic books' stuff to talk about.
In case you guys are behind too there's
a new episode of Arrow tonight,
Deathstroke is coming back so be sure to
watch it. I'll post my video after the episode airs.
While you guys wait for all that stuff to drop you can
click here to catch up on last night's bananas episode of the Flash. Haha.
And you click here for last week's
Agent Carter.
Thank you so much watching. Everybody let's high-five. I'll see you tonight.